por cada tres horas de juegos de
computadora sandra tiene dos horas de
tarea por cada 7 horas de juegos de
computadora madison tiene 4 horas de
tarea que punto puede decirnos cuántas
horas de tarea tuvo sandra si jugó
juegos de computadora por 5 horas
tenemos esta gráfica y tenemos estas dos
líneas primero tenemos que determinar si
este eje son las horas de tarea y este
eje son las horas de computadora cual
línea le pertenece a quien entonces si
sandra tiene dos horas de tarea por cada
tres horas de juegos de computadora si
me voy a este punto que son dos horas de
tarea y me muevo esta altura que grafica
me daría una coordenada x de 3 esta
gráfica roja me enseñaría que por dos
horas de tarea tendría tres horas de
juegos de computadora y por lo tanto le
pertenece a sandra
ahora me preguntan qué punto puede
decirnos cuántos horas de tarea tuvo
sandra sí jugó juegos de computadora por
5 horas me voy a 5 horas de juegos de
computadora y subo a la gráfica y sandra
que es la gráfica roja y llegó al punto
ce así que la respuesta debe ser c
y en efecto